you got to start getting these NDA
signed you know what I was thinking that
but that's like
appreciate the date to Olive Garden or
wherever someone takes you whatever I do
like Olive Garden of course you do
because Alfredo because you're a real
one listen you told me how you eat your
McDonald's
I totally believe that you like Olive
Garden because it's crazy it is so good
with that being said here's a contract
if this goes any further I'd like to
know that this stays between you and I
okay I'll have you you can send it out
for me and then you could sue them yeah
I could be your lawyer just hire me okay
I don't have a law degree or anything
but I can figure it out you know I think
they'd be scared of you
yeah maybe yeah there it is sweetie bye